we made it back to season two of game of
thrones after a somewhat short break
from doing season analysis videos and
for season two i'm going to look at
specific aspects as to what makes the
season special because obviously the
writing acting directing and other
general aspects of the season are
outstanding i mainly want to focus on
the more unique qualities that season 2
possesses that makes it so great
first we have numerous scenes that are
solely driven by character development
generally for these types of scenes they
are interlaced with some form of plot
development but after re-watching season
2 there are a lot of scenes where
characters are just purely talking to
each other and learning about what
drives them their motivations wants
desires and their backstory i love the
casual nature of these scenes because
they are both intriguing and the
dialogue is rich to the bone with so
much information to be devoured it also
allows george rr martin to fill in this
dialogue with witty uses of literary
devices that makes listening to these
scenes even more entertaining you want
to be hand of the king you want to rule
this is what ruling is lying on a bed of
weeds ripping them out by the root one
by one before they strangle you in your
sleep you'd think there would be some
form of dialogue fatigue but with so
many complex characters the scenes never
become boring the best example of this
is the reoccurring talks with tyrion and
cersei their conversations don't
necessarily push the plot forward but it
instead gives us a major behind the
scenes look as to how these characters
operate and their dysfunctional dynamic
the utter disdain cersei has towards
tyrion for killing their mother
seriously going on about the sin she's
committed by having kids with jaime
admitting how cruel joffrey has become
and making wicked and vile threats are
just a few examples as to why their
dynamic is so intriguing the ebb and
flow of cersei and tyrion is also very
interesting because they don't just have
a flat relationship where they hate each
other
deep down they are still a family and
despite cersei genuinely hating tyrion
he's really the only one she can
personally talk to this unlocks the more
passionate side of cersei that is never
able to be expressed since she's so
closed off when around other characters
and thus makes us like her significantly
more and this is just one fantastic
pairing and in this season there's
another one which is tywin and arya and
again their scenes together don't push
the plot forward but they still manage
to be some of the best scenes in the
show tywin on his own is a chad who can
even make reading a dictionary enjoyable
but pairing him with another great
character like arya you end up creating
a winning formula since arya is much
smarter than people her age she is able
to keep up with tywin on a
conversational level and it's extremely
cathartic whenever she impresses him
you're too smart for your own good has
anyone told you that
yes i also love the irony of how well
these two characters get along despite
him being one of the biggest villains
who essentially kills her family it
again goes to show how human these
characters are when you peel back all
the exterior conflict and they profusely
bleed character developments arya going
on in detail about what she loves and
admires and how in lecturing her as if
she's his own daughter is beautiful and
this is all done with just dialogue and
no reliance on action i think it's
hilarious how david and dan try to
replicate this magic in season 7 by
bringing together tyrion and cersei
again but it came nowhere close to the
quality they were aiming for because of
how contrived and stupid the scene was
i'd go into what was wrong with it but i
talked about that in my video on season
7. it goes to show how much we took
these chill dialogue scenes for granted
since we barely get any in the later
seasons and we instead get way more
action because inherently action is much
easier to write since it's primarily
people whacking each other with swords
instead of the complexities that goes
into the dialogue of season 2's rich
characters
as a bit of a follow-up to the last
points i want to go into how heavily the
dialogue is submerged and tensioned
given how season 1 turned out for ned
stark in which he was betrayed by
virtually everyone in king's landing it
makes all the dialogue scenes
surrounding tyrion have a lot of tension
because we don't know who we can trust i
think this is the other part of george
rr martin's great dialogue secret
formula because not only is every line
teeming with intelligence everything is
also imbued with some form of deep
rooting conflict
whether that be cersei silently
calculating the demise of tyrion
littlefinger having a rotating wheel of
allegiances varus potentially being too
friendly for possible sinister
intentions and paistel secretly obeying
cersei every dialogue interaction is
like maneuvering around an ever-shifting
field of minds you never know what
you're going to get with these
characters and it makes the story feel
unpredictable but obviously in a good
way and not in the severe expectations
kind of way in season 8 and to ease this
unpredictable nature that got ned's star
killed tyrion knows how to play the game
of thrones this offers a great point of
contrast between the first two seasons
because for season 1 we were following
someone like ourselves who didn't know
how king's landing operated but for
season 2 we as an audience know the
dangers of king's landing and by
following a character that shares our
similar experience level the
protagonist's journey through king's
landing offers something new from this
new perspective we get well-matched
intellectual scenes like tyrion feeding
three separate people different versions
of information to find out which person
tells cersei voting out janos slint
because it was very sus for getting that
stark killed and blackmailing lancel
with the information of him having sex
with cersei this contrast between ned
and tyrion makes tyrion seem like an
absolute badass and us slowly seeing him
rise over the course of season 2 is so
triumphant and this all stems from the
fact that each and every dialogue scene
has a lot of tension since tiring is
constantly overcoming conflict on both a
macro and micro level it makes all of
his scenes entertaining and this goes
for almost every dialogue seen in season
2 which makes episodes without any
action still feel extremely tense and we
get the cathartic sense of overcoming
obstacles
for a quick aspect i want to go into the
interconnected sense of the world that
season 2 possesses for season 1 we had
plot lines are relatively self-contained
until when catelyn made the decision to
capture tyrion to which that decision
set forth a rippling tidal wave of
consequences towards ned stark and the
overall lannister and stark relationship
but for season 2 because of those
ramifications of season one's finale the
entire world is dragged into the battle
of the five kings whole plot lines are
intertwined and every action that
happens immediately impacts another
characters reading and reacting to the
events that happened in the episode
prior characters crossing over and
interacting with each other and
conflicts arising from different actions
made by other people like the young
rachel capturing winterfell season 2 has
an infectious flow because each plotline
serves a common narrative
going from rob stark winning a battle to
taiwan immediately maulding and yelling
at his top officials making mistakes
this cause and effect flow is engrossing
and the transition from scene to scene
is practically seamless because it picks
up the story right where we left off in
comparison to other seasons where the
plotlines get so far separated that we
lose the interconnected feeling to me
the battle of the 5 king story feels so
special because of that interweaving
conflict that ties everyone together and
seeing who comes out on top is
entrancing also as a small detail i even
love the subtle beginning of season 2
where each scene starts with the red
comet in the sky which illustrates the
idea that despite westeros being massive
everyone is still a part of the same
world
for what i think is the best aspect of
the season i want to go into the
intimidating build-up and crazy battle
of the black water the first four
seasons have a great king's landing
narrative but for season two the massive
obstacle of stannis baratheon leaves a
constant state of oncoming doom that our
characters have to overcome to make the
conflict even more daunting tyrion is
constantly at odds with his own peers
and it makes the defense preparations
almost impossible this cleverly plays
into the satisfying story formula of
tyrion being an underdog and still
managing to defeat stannis army and none
of it is contrived tyrion cleverly
blackmails lancel and figures out
information involving wildfire to which
he formulates a plan to put that
wildfire on his ship and sends it into
stance's fleet to blow it up and he
steps up to the occasion of leader when
joffrey deserves his post by leading a
successful counter-attack this is a
perfect example of an underdog conflict
if he compared this to the battle of the
bastards which is a similar complex
scenario jon snow virtually does nothing
right and constantly makes mistakes that
should cost him his life and he still
manages to win
this victory to me is nowhere near as
satisfying because it doesn't feel
earned from how contrived the writing is
for the blackwater we have a character
whose only strength is his wits and he
expertly utilizes his intellect to
outplay stannis
tyrion isn't bumbling around making
grave errors until taiwan saves the day
tyrion is the true hero despite tywin
taking all the glory now you can argue
that tywin showing up to save the day
with the tyrells can count as a deus ex
machina but that was set up by him
leaving harrenhal the episode prior this
comes nowhere close to the idiocy of
sansa not telling jon that she had the
support of the veil and letting him
attack ramsay against terrible odds just
so that she could save the day at the
end for whatever horrendous idea she had
tyrion didn't have a choice because
stannis was attacking on his own
schedule now looking at the actual
battle i think that blackwater is one of
the most special sequences in the show
not just because of the big explosion
but because we've been teased a lot in
terms of david and dan skipping over
battles to the point that now that we
actually have a big scale action
sequence it thoroughly blows us away and
that's essentially a literal statement
because we are all floored by the pure
awe of the gigantic explosion the
cathartic boom of emotions that we all
felt was orgasmic and the fact that game
of thrones increased its skill
significantly and just season 2 made
every fan have wet dreams for what was
to come in later seasons the overall
action was still executed very well and
the visceral nature of violence was
thoroughly engaging quick insert shots
of people dying raised the intensity
wide shots showing the battle gave the
scene plenty of clarity and following
characters as they experienced their
highs and lows was riveting between the
hound finally breaking and yelling at
joffrey entering hitting its proudest
moment makes us experience a wide range
of emotions of hopelessness and
triumphant victory the blackwater is
outstanding and it manages to both
entertainingly drive the king's landing
story and both paid off an absolute
perfection this is why the blackwater
episode is one of my favorites
for the last point of the video i
quickly wanted to touch on each subplot
because i don't want to leave out any
big chunks of season 2 since a lot of
the video has been focused on king's
landing i'll start with theon greyjoy
since he surprisingly has a magnificent
story in season two and when i say
surprisingly this is a character who
from season 1 was somewhat of a
douchebag who i couldn't really find
myself to like but in season 2 george r
martin perfectly encapsulates how
conflicted and torn apart theon greyjoy
is should he be loyal to the family he's
technically related to or to the family
that cares for him more and raised him
throughout season 1 we've seen the
unsubtly question his identity of being
a stark and now that development is
being explored to extreme detail i think
the ending is perfect for theon in which
he tries his absolute hardest to be a
true ironborn but is ultimately rejected
and handed over to the enemy thus
reaffirming that he's more of a stark
than he is a great joy to me that's an
excellent character arc and it turns a
person he probably didn't care about
into someone you can't help but love
despite how flawed and terrible they are
at their core
for rob stark his plot line is normally
amusing since he's a likable lead
protagonist at the center stage of a
sprawling war however there are a couple
aspects in his plot line that i have a
gripe with i wish there was more
build-up and payoff for his strategic
victories instead of that aspect of a
subplot falling into the background it
makes the war seem like there are barely
any obstacles and no hard to achieve
objectives that our characters have to
face like in king's landing it takes the
emphasis off of the war and primarily
puts it onto his relationship which as
an additional side story that's great it
just shouldn't take up most of his story
on top of the fact that meaning to
listen in the first place came across as
rob stark immediately having a crush on
this one female you think that since he
promised to marry a freight girl he take
it half seriously and not overly
interest himself in other women as a
comparison in the books rob gets injured
and the person who nurses him back to
health is the girl he falls in love with
but he makes love with her in a low
moment of grief because he just found
out that rickon and bran were killed by
theon and to not dishonor her he decided
to marry her in secret the show takes a
pretty massive departure where rob stark
just gets horny while on the battlefield
although i still like the romantic
aspect later on and they are really cute
couple if this aspect of the show was a
bit more accurate to the books than i
think it would be better along with
having more time on the actual battle of
the five kings since it's a tv show with
limited time i can understand cutting
out some material the introduction of
stannis baratheon in this whole plotline
is pretty much flawless he's such a
detailed and well-rounded character who
contrasts his more likable brother which
makes an interesting rivalry he's
essentially an unstoppable swift force
of justice who does not mess around with
playing dirty the twist of him using
black magic to kill his brother was
crazy and opened up a magical avenue of
intrigue into the story of game of
thrones which leads into the blackwater
battle so stannis as usual is a manus
arya sarka is a fun journey where she
narrowly escapes death on multiple
occasions deep down we know she's safe
but what we don't know is if our
favorite character in the show hot pie
is going to survive
so it has more tension because the
characters surrounding arya aren't
invincible and the main highlight in her
subplot this season is obviously her
relationship with tywin but i already
went over that so let's move on to jon
snow out of the first four seasons and
this also goes for daenerys as well is
that i think their two plot lines this
season are the least interesting
at the end of season 1 we get really
hyped up for going north of the wall but
in reality most of the scenes aren't
that fun or entertaining and generally
feature characters brooding around
forced labor at crasters and lots of
walking and digging but the whole
setting is very immersive and offers up
some breathtaking set pieces so at least
the visuals are wonderful things do get
really good when eager shows up and that
doesn't happen until the last half of
the season i do adore how she perfectly
challenges jon snow's ideals and their
debates about what makes someone free
like how jon snow swore an oath and now
he can never make love again the subplot
does end with a great climax of corn
half and sacrificing himself so jon can
win the trust of the free folk it's just
a shame that the first half of the
season jon doesn't have much to do
lastly we have daenerys and as i said
before her subplot this season is a bit
lackluster similar to jon's subplot the
first four episodes are mostly her
bumbling around in the desert until she
finds carth so naturally this in
comparison to something like season 3
where she's getting the unsullied will
be objectively worse even in qarth the
main conflict dany encounters isn't
amazing because a solution to her
problem is very convenient since sir joy
finds an all-knowing lady who never
comes back into the story and her powers
are never explained so as it stands it
feels like david and dan use quothi as a
cheap mcguffin plot device to move the
story forward besides those flaws
daenerys story still ends with a banger
by seeing visions and being revisited by
a fake khal drogo the sacrifice she
makes to leave him in her ultimate
paradise is heartbreaking and acts as a
great metaphor of leaving the past
behind to become the mother of dragons
so despite john and daenerys having some
flawed aspects in their stories they
still have some good qualities that
don't make their season 2 plot lines bad
by any means
so all together from the excellent
dialogue scenes are drenched in intrigue
dialogue that has also submerged in
tension the outstanding blackwater and
king's landing plotline the
interconnected and epic sense of the
battle of the five kings and some superb
plotlines makes season 2 great thank you
for watching and i'll try not to take
another big break for making the season
3 analysis